hagamos un repaso del último vídeo si tú
me dabas un precio de un subyacente un
precio de ejercicio así como la tasa
libre de riesgo y el tiempo de
expiración también la volatilidad o la
desviación estándar de los logaritmos de
regreso si miras estas seis cosas si me
dabas estas seis cosas podríamos
ponerlas en la fórmula de black and sons
sustituye las una fórmula de black and
sons y después de esto digamos que lo
ponemos estas seis cosas en la fórmula
de black and shots entonces ponemos por
aquí que va a ser para la fórmula de
black angels
black angels y muy bien voy a poner para
ti el precio apropiado para esta opción
de compra europea y todo suena muy
sencillo y algunos de estos son
sencillos de lograr a calcular por
ejemplo el precio del subyacente es
fácil de encontrar el precio de
ejercicio pues es parte del contrato así
que ya lo conoces luego la tasa libre de
riesgo hay algunos prefijos para está en
el mercado de fondo de dinero con el
cual te lo puede dar el gobierno y de
esta forma lo puedes estimar o calcular
y el tiempo de expiración pues también
lo conoces tú sabes la fecha de hoy así
que vas a saber en qué momento van a
expirar todas estas cosas así que estas
cosas son bastante sencillas pero ahora
vamos a concentrarnos un poco en la
volatilidad así que como lo harías para
medir la desviación estándar de los
logaritmos de regreso y ahora una de las
suposiciones de la fórmula de black and
sol es que esto es una constante es una
propiedad intrínseca del seguro y bien
la única forma en que puedes medir o
calcular todo esto es a través de tomar
los datos históricos de la desviación
estándar de los
ritmos de regreso así que la forma en
como la gente normalmente lo hace es
diciendo bien pues cual cuales han sido
históricamente las desviaciones estándar
de los logaritmos de regreso sobre algún
periodo de tiempo donde seguramente no
hayan cambiado de forma drástica y luego
usarlos para esto y así lograr tener
alguna aproximación mediante los precios
y bien todo esto es interesante pero es
muy importante saber y recordar que esto
es simplemente una estimación es una
estimación por lo que no hay manera en
que se sepa realmente esto y es incluso
para ciertos casos donde puedes suponer
que hay alguna propiedad intrínseca
constante como la volatilidad que vaya
esta misma siendo constante sobre la
vida de estas opciones así que esto es
solamente una estimación en la cual es
importante saber pero lo que es
interesante de todo esto es como han
sido negociados estas opciones de compra
han sido negociadas todo el tiempo y
puedes observar los precios para estas
opciones de compra
ahora si tú sabes exactamente cuánto es
esto porque sabes en cuanto lo está
estimando el mercado entonces déjame lo
escribo por aquí tú sabes cuánto cree el
mercado que debería de costar así que el
mercado cree esto basado en sus actuales
transacciones en sus basados en sus
actuales transacciones y esto es lo que
el mercado dice que es el precio
correcto y lo puedes observar
simplemente también con estas cosas de
acá y luego puedes tomar todo esto para
trabajarlo en la fórmula de black and
soul y al estimarlo acercarlo a lo que
el mercado cree que es lo mejor en su
precio y la respuesta es sí esto es
donde dicha idea de cuando la gente
habla de la volatilidad en el mercado o
incluso cuando hablan de la volatilidad
de una tasa o incluso cuando el mercado
trata de decirla qué volatilidad habrá y
bien podemos observar como en el mercado
se están negociando las opciones y
podemos tomar toda esta información que
será sustituida en la fórmula de black
and soul y decir mira basado en el hecho
de los datos históricos
es que pagan los 5 pesos por esta opción
y todas estas variables ellos deberían
asumir que la desviación estándar de los
logaritmos de regreso es para este
seguro dicha volatilidad ahora digamos
que las cosas lucen realmente de miedo
pues en el mercado se toman una que da
una gran cantidad de decisiones por lo
que luego la gente tiene que pagar más
por dicha opción y se va a tratar de ir
implicando una volatilidad así que
cuando escuchas que la gente habla de
volatilidad implícita es el hecho de
quien actualmente negocia sobre la
volatilidad implícita entonces la
volatilidad implícita es eso es de lo
que hablan ellos dicen mira las opciones
están negociando todo el tiempo podemos
nosotros usar dicho precio cuando en el
mercado se cree que es cierto precio por
lo que deberíamos trabajarlo con base a
este con la fórmula de black angels y
figurarnos porque nosotros sabemos todos
estos factores pues podemos ver estas
cosas de aquí pero basado en lo que el
mercado está negociando las opciones así
que esto es muy interesante aunque en
algunos niveles
es algo básico